es ist okay wenn ich hier auch ein was
hier doch nochmal damit meine damen und
herren ich habe bereits vor einer woche
auf temptation island reagiert hat schon
mal das eine oder andere auch mal haben
wir machtlos
du bist schon mehrmals fremdgegangen
also temptation island ist echt zu
dieses unterste vom untersten was gerade
im fernsehen läuft sie meine reaktion
auf die erste folge allerdings nicht
gesehen haben sollte er sage ich euch
noch mal ganz kurz worum es dabei geht
das hier ist erstmal das intro von
versuchung im paradies temptation island
zweite station einen geht es darum dass
vier pärchen jeweils bestehend aus mann
und frau auf eine insel fahren und dort
voneinander getrennt werden
die männer gehen in ein haus und die
frauen gehen in ein haus zu den männern
werden dann irgendwelche models bzw
single ladies geschickt und zu den
vergebenen frauen werden heizungen
männer geschickt mit den aufgaben
ich finde es immer noch so ihre diese
singles haben die aufgabe die vergebenen
leute aus ihrer beziehung zu locken und
versuchen die davon zu überzeugen eine
affäre mit sich anzufangen und dass sie
halt fremdgehen super idee lass uns
daraus eine serie machen
es gibt da noch so ein paar special
sachen innerhalb dieser serie also
irgendein konzept in dem konzept da will
ich jetzt gar nicht darauf eingehen aber
das geht ja quasi darum dass die
zwischendurch dates haben müssen mit
anderen leuten
darum wird unter anderem auch heute
gehen allerdings wären die pärchen
wirklich komplett voneinander getrennt
die kriegen nichts mit was bei den
anderen irgendwie abläuft ob die
irgendwie fremd gehen mit dem anders aus
abends beim lagerfeuer sehen sie einige
aufnahmen die von der anderen personen
in der beziehung getätigt wurden also
was da halt so ablief
in der anderen villa und direkt zu
beginn von der heutigen folge sieht halt
unsere kandidatin sibylle das ist die
hier die heißt eigentlich nicht die
bilder aber wir haben die bilder genau
weil sie seinen komischen namen hatte
sie bildet sie zu beginn der heutigen
folge direkt was
ja ihr freund so gemacht hat ich weiß
wie die frauen ticken und ich will gar
nicht wissen was mich noch alles
erwartet also der freund von der sibylle
der klaus der heiße auch eigentlich
anders aber wir haben den klaus genannte
klaus hat mit anderen mädels getanzt
das musste sie sibylle dann erstmal
verkraften und ist mit den worten zurück
in die mädels villa gegangen sehen sich
von den single männern erwartet
alkohol
sie sagt nicht irgendwie hanno oder so
die sagt einfach meine liebe sibylle was
möchtest du denn trinken das härteste
das also mensch das haben wir heute
leider nie sibylle soll dann auf jeden
fall für diese ganzen singlemänner mal
zusammenfassen was sie da am lagerfeuer
gesehen hat was der klaus gemacht hat
und dass es ihre zusammenfassung das war
jetzt echt krass ist aber ich habe hier
auch viel mit ihm erlebt und das ist so
das ist so
ja so ist das einfach während christina
schon anstößt kommt auch ihr freund
selber vom lagerfeuer zurück also die
männer waren auch am lagerfeuer haben
gesehen was ihre frauen so gemacht haben
und kommen nun auch zurück in ihre villa
heute abend passiert hoffentlich nicht
mehr so viel wird am liebsten direkt
todmüde ins bett
also der fabian wird am liebsten todmüde
ins bett fallen ich mein so ein drehtag
jetzt natürlich auch anstrengend und
dann kommen sie allerdings in der villa
an
[Musik]
ja das sieht auch auf jeden fall nach
toten wieder ins bett fallen aus nach
dieser trinkerei und feierei da als sie
dann wieder zu hause angekommen sind von
den in einer beziehung stehenden männern
mit den single ladies unterhält sich der
fabian der seine freundin echt vermisst
mit dem klaus das ist echt schwierig das
nach so einer kurzen zeit vermisst man
irgendwie so seine frau
der fabian verletzt seine frau und macht
sie richtig gedanken und der klaus
antwortet einfach das hier gar nichts
der klaus vermisst die sybille glaube
ich gar nicht so richtig aber dann hat
er noch eine offenbar um die ganze
geschichte hier doch sehr viel dazu der
vorarbeiter hält diese mit dem klausel
man sagt ja was hast du diesen job
gemacht ich zum beispiel habe echt voll
viel gelernt sagt der klausel ich habe
auch viel dazu gelernt dann sehe was was
hast du so gelernt die mine neue sprache
und mathe keine ahnung was ich war auf
einer insel und habe geguckt ob ich
fremd gehen und das ist dann überlegst
natürlich auch soja wie gibt es auch bei
ihr weiter der pad doch nicht wirklich
mit zum flutlicht da an seinem rollladen
dingsdag ich nehme immer eine softbox
mit ins bett gehen wir allerdings nun
von der männer villa zurück in die
frauen villa wo die sibylle mal das
ganze für sich bisher so zusammenfasst
ich versteh mich super
ich mag alle unnormal ich mag alles so
normal ich glaube wenn james nicht da
wäre wäre es echt blöd weil erhältst du
dich tragen wie ich rede ja nee man
liebt keinen menschen wegen den inneren
werten oder irgendwas sondern einfach
nur weil er wie man selbst redet also
deutsch und wie man tanzt als quasi
belegt die hat damit ja mehr oder
weniger schon so ein kleines
liebesgeständnis an den james abgelegt
dass es einer dieser single männer denen
sie dort kennengelernt hatte und der
james hat das als antwort
[Musik]
mit dir einfach abzuwarten
am 16
die freundin von fabian namens ziehen ja
das ist die hier der satz beschreibt
wirklich diese komplette serie und den
kompletten intelligenzquotienten der
teil den wir haben alle schon eine
kleinigkeit sensibel haid in sich werden
[Musik]
sensibilität dass er heißt eigentlich
sensibel hat aber gut okay ist ein
lacher zwischendurch vielleicht hat sie
sich einfach nur versprochen dann kam
auf jeden fall eine werbeunterbrechung
und so geht's weiter direkt mit dem
ersten satz ich habe ein stern gesehen
leute ich kann darf die stern gesehen
glückwunsch geil also es wird noch
schlimmer habe aber s runter gefahren
ist neben mir
am nächsten morgen wie die sibylle dann
von der ca
darauf angesprochen warum sie denn gar
nicht mehr traurig war und warum ihr das
mit ihrem freund klaus gar nicht mehr so
nahe gegangen ist dann hat gar keine
traurigkeit
ich glaube diese piraten kleines
alkoholproblem aber ich will jetzt gar
kein fass aufmachen oder lostreten
werden wir treten ein fass los hier
gehen rüber von der frauen villa wieder
in die männer villa wo die single ladies
versuchen fabian rumzukriegen mit einer
sehr komischen taktik haben
kannst du mir mal kurz ich verbrenne
carola bluhm
ich verbrenne grad
ja nicht verbrennen gerade etwas hin
doch finde ich sehr lobenswert dass er
wirklich direkt sagt hey ich habe in
meiner freundin vorher abgemacht
massieren machen wir nicht so weit gehen
wir nicht und das finde ich auch gut so
jetzt geht es allerdings darum dass die
vergebenen personen eine single personen
zugeteilt bekommen und ein mast dates
haben müssen also sie müssen auf ein
date mit dieser person gehen und das
sagt klaus dazu ich freue mich sie
kennenzulernen mal ein bisschen alleine
zu sein
klaus ist eigentlich in der beziehung
und sagt dann ich freue mich sie
kennenzulernen
doch nicht nur die vergebenen männer
bekommen singles zugeteilt für ein date
sondern auch die frauen
und so geht es bei denen ich hoffe dass
sein freund das sieht wie sie sagt auch
mit dem typen wollte ich doch eigentlich
heute auf dem date geben allerdings
bekommt dann die lena ihr date zugeteilt
in der luft verbringen
wer wer ist dominik rund 925 okay jetzt
wissen alle wer dominik ist nah heißt
dominik 25 jahre alt und die
beschreibung darunter hast unordnung ist
ja nun allerdings wieder zurück in der
männer villa wo einer der vergebenen
typen ein komisches angebot bekommt hier
eine freundin gerade dreierbeziehung ja
wer weiß vielleicht gar nicht mehr
zurück diesmal ganz crazy
annäherungsversuche von sabir haft ich
auf märkten allerdings nun zum nächsten
date zwischen oliver und lisa könnte
deinen rücken massieren der bisschen
verspannung hast du vielleicht kann ich
die eben ein bisschen lösung und
vielleicht auch wegzaubern lasse einfach
gut sein damit verläuft ist ein sieg ist
also der olli war es echt der date könig
doch was ich mich einfach so ein
bisschen frage ist die tatsache der
freund von der lisa also der freund von
der die da gerade liegt hat ja
eigentlich gesagt nein was ihn doch
doch der oliver massiert die jetzt die
müsste doch eigentlich was gegen haben
es ist okay wenn ich hier auch einen
passieren darf
[Musik]
für lena und christina geht es gemeinsam
mit den single jungs in die natur okay
also zwei von den vergebenen mädels
haben einen doppel date mit ihren
singles irgendwo in der natur also ich
bin echt gespannt was sie machen
die elefanten
leid dass sie mit den abhängen müssen
halt ein blümchen wenn wir davor steht
das ding ist echt großen respekt
elefanten alt amis respekt dafür dass
ihr elefanten seite kann mich jetzt aber
nicht an meiner hand einsaugen oder so
ne
du bist die pille zwei punkten geht die
dahin so und will so ein check machen
mit dem elefant ich meine gehirnzellen
streiten sich da oben wieder wer als er
selbst doch die gehen da half auch für
christinas freund cyber geht's jetzt los
der hat ja und date also ich bin ja
nicht so der beste schwimmer aber ich
kann schwimmen sprechen kannst du
anscheinend nicht so gut ein engel nicht
genau ein kleines stoff guter satz
bei einem date einfach sagen hey wir
noch ein kleines arschloch kommt immer
gut und dann beschreibt der cloud auch
noch frauen allgemeinen die versuchung
ist halt immer irgendwie so zu erziehen
weil sowieso eine mama und ich habe eine
überzeugung die rechnung auch was mit
dem satz ich hab echt da können wir doch
einfach jetzt beenden
wenn euch meine reaction hier auf die
zweite folge das ist eine 4 luca werde
ich meine zweite reaktion auf dem
täschchen island hier gefallen hat dann
das gerne einen daumen hoch bei diesem
gerät da wenn ich auch auf die dritte
folge demnächst reagieren soll schreibt
wir auch unten in die kommentare wo und
wem ihr denkt dass er als erstes fremd
gehen wird und ihr habt ja schon gemerkt
ich habe heute ein bisschen anders drauf
reagiert ich habe die folge vorher schon
angeschaut habt schnipsel vorbereitet
ich glaube das bringt so bisschen
frischen wind in die rag dabei hätte ich
ja eh vorbei
[Musik]